this is an app for the Russian
[Music]
[Applause]
military
[Music]
this is an ad for the Chinese
military
for and this is an ad for the almighty
American
[Music]
Military this is the story of a soldier
who operates your nation's Patriot
missile defense
systems it begins in
California with a little girl raised by
two
moms although I had a fairly typical
childhood took ballet played violin
I also marched for
equality I like to think I've been
defending freedom from an early age so
yeah the US military is in a bit of a
pickle a military needs to recruit
strong tough Warriors that are willing
to die for their country and that's
exactly the kind of energy Russia's and
China's military ads are tapping into
this already looks going this is
going to be wild bro look at him this
will literally stab you in
the face but America's military ads
they're not trying to recruit the strong
they're not trying to recruit the brave
no they're trying to recruit the diverse
recruiting and retaining a more diverse
Army is the goal so diversity is very
important to us the all volunteer
military has reached crisis levels of
low recruitment while at the same time
the American public's perception of the
Armed Forces is increasingly divided a
recent Gallup poll found confidence in
the US military is at its lowest level
in over two decades only 60% of people
told Gallup they had confidence in the
US mil military at the same time some
military branches are falling short of
their yearly recruiting goals by the
thousands the Army is set to fall 15,000
recruits short this year so yeah
needless to say the US military is
running out of soldiers in fact the US
military has not had this much trouble
getting new recruits since the Vietnam
War ended I love the US military it is a
fantastic institution well anything that
has that much money thrown at it can
develop a lot of bad habits and become
like an obese trath
and the soldiers they do have well when
you ask them why they join the military
half of them give good answers but the
other half of them answer was something
like this you join the Army how do you
join the Army I don't know for money I
huh for
money the Army free food but why should
you even care about this you should care
about this because whenever the military
of any country has this much trouble
getting new recruits especially when
that country is prone to getting into
Wars once a big war does break out you
can bet that a draft is right around the
corner stay dangerous and let's get into
it in 1996 two authors named Neil how
and William stuss published a very scary
book that predicted exactly where we're
at today called the fourth turning and
this book perfectly explains why the US
military is in trouble today in the book
the authors explain that history is not
random history doesn't happen randomly
in a straight line no over the past 500
years anglo-american history has
repeated itself in very well-defined
cycles of 80 to 100 years these 80 to
100 years Cycles are called seculum and
each of these Cycles or are made up
of four turnings of around two decades
each the first turning in the cycle is a
high an upbeat era where there's
opportunity Unity trust in the
government you believe in the nation and
there's a new Civic order that has just
replaced the old regime and overall
things are just great think of the end
of World War II people loved the country
they trusted the government people were
having kids they were proud to be
American they were buying houses left
and right it was America's golden years
but then comes the second turning which
we call the Awakening this is when a lot
of people get alienated by the status
quo you don't trust the government as
much anymore you start fighting back and
resisting the status quo think of the
hippie movement the racial movements and
the social justice protests of the 60s
and70s and this Awakening eventually
pays the way to the third turning the
unraveling in the unraveling Society
feels like it's going downhill
corruption and institution starts
running rampants so people naturally
trust the government and institutions
less people naturally become more
individualistic and in the unraveling
the seed is planted for a new Civic
order to take over and so this leads us
into the climax with the fourth turning
which we call the crisis this moment in
history the crisis is exactly what it
sounds like people aren't proud to be
American anymore they really don't trust
the government anymore as corruption is
so Blan it's insulting we feel more
entitled as individuals more
self-centered while at the same time we
feel like the future looks really really
Bleak for the Next Generation it feels
feel like there's just too many things
to fix so we just live in the Nile until
some sort of Revolution happens this
revolution can be peaceful or violent
but either way the old Civic order gets
replaced with a new one and thus the 80
to 100e cycle starts all over again so
if you felt any of this that I just
described if you feel the anxiety in the
air the bleakness about the future you
are not alone because this is exactly
where we're supposed to be at this is
where we are in the seculum we're going
to have a full video on this soon by the
way so subscribe and this is also the
environment that the US military finds
itself in right now and yet the US
military seems completely oblivious to
all of
[Music]
this back in the day nobody knew what
war really entailed until they were on
the ground and it was too late to turn
around but today Millennials and gen Z
know exactly how brutal Life as a
soldier can be they grew up watching war
movies they grew up through the wars in
the Middle East they've heard the horror
stories from veterans about PTSD
depression anxiety or worse and pretty
much everyone knows about how poorly
they treat veterans once they do come
home well the most difficult part about
coming home was getting off the ship in
the middle of the night of San
Francisco and they just said go
home I mean what do you mean go home
well yeah I said well how am I supposed
to get home from here to
Ventura and this is
about oh oh God maybe 1 or 2:00 in the
morning yeah in the middle of the night
we walked approximately I would say
maybe 5 miles to get to Highway 80 and
so then I hit T from there and uh they
gave us our discharge that was it they
never told you uh you know get check for
or anything else like that so I I've had
uh the ringing in my ears uh since
1952 when these guys are on 15 and 20
different medications a day today it's
no wonder the suicide rate is 20 some a
day it's it's grotesque and wrong and
just Flatout evil the inv the basically
the warehousing of the people that
served
America forget about those guys just put
them on drugs and pay him something to
sit home every human being wants to know
that they're adding value and here's the
thing Ty back to what we talked about
earlier this would be worth it if
soldiers actually felt like they were
making a positive difference in the
world but today everyone knows how BS
these wars are heck even veterans that
gave their Blood Sweat and Tears are now
looking back at the wars they fought
with doubts in fact take a listen to
Travis Haley a legendary war hero that
runs a company called Haley strategic
today that I really respect the other
thing is oh you fought dick Chen's
War okay um you know you fought for the
military-industrial complex uh 911
conspiracy all these things so if you
are one of those conspiracy theorists
and you think that it was Dick Cheney's
War Bush's War um to to Simply make
money you know would they say Halle
Burton made $48 billion and took
advantage of hundreds of millions of
dollars of taxpayers money if you think
that Al-Qaeda had nothing to do with
Saddam Hussein's um regime if you think
uh that 911 was was not tied to that
whatsoever and the list goes on and on
and on all the conspiracies out there I
believe you are absolutely unequivocally
without a
doubt correct and if this is the general
sensus of what everyone believes in why
would you ever want to sign up for that
why would you ever want to die in a
meaningless war and then there's the
[Music]
pay when there's no unifying mission to
get people to join the military for
example like the Nazis or something most
kids that do join the military will
still join for the benefits they'll join
for the pay for the chance to get a
college degree for a reliable salary or
benefits for their family why you Army
cuz I was broke but even that isn't
looking as attractive anymore with
minimum wages rising and a whole new
range of work opportunities that weren't
there before what is the point of
joining the military the Army only pays
a starting salary of $23,000 that's
$5,000 less than what chick-fil pays for
their lowest earning new team members so
if you can make more money working at a
fast food restaurant without having to
leave your home without having to get
yelled that without having to
potentially die once again why would
this generation ever pick the military
if we don't turn turn our recruiting
situation around I can't guarantee you
that the Army won't have to make some
more substantial potential for structure
reductions uh because we we've got to
make sure that our units for example
that are on the immediate response Force
are manned adequately so that they're
ready to go and then of course there are
the ads here's the thing conservative
Americans have always been the
military's biggest recruitment base and
yet the military is completely ignoring
them instead the military is trying to
Rebrand themselves as an inclusive
Institution thinking that this is what's
going to attract a new demographic of
Americans to serve when in reality all
they did was alienate the only group of
people they had a shot of recruiting in
the first place ladies and gentlemen I
need to talk
about this military recruiting video I I
just it just balls my blood and for
those of you not from Texas ball mean
boil it balls my blood to
see the
stupidity in our country this is the
story of a soldier who operates your
nation's Patriot missile defense
systems missiles and cartoon
forms that makes me think of kids not
grown men or women
California I'm US Army Corporal Emma
Malone Lord and I answered my calling
we're screwed people you get it you get
it like can you imagine that Russian guy
coming up against that girl no offense
to that girl no offense to her lesbian
mothers no offense to the marching no
offense to equality no offense to any of
that but if you give me a you know East
Village lesbian vers Vladimir Putin
who's going to win what are we doing
what are we doing none of the big tough
guys that you want protecting the
country are going to be inspired by a
cartoon about lesbian moms but out of
all this recruiting chaos there is still
one branch that does not have a
recruiting
problem
many will hear the
calling few will earn the
title United States
Marine even though the rest of the
military is sinking the Marines are
still going strong in hitting the
recruitment numbers without any problems
what is the difference you know seeing
the the recruiting problems that the
Army and the Navy have Marine Corps
doesn't but what's the difference in the
Marine Corps Recruiting but I think
anybody that's served can tell the
difference between Marine Corps
Recruiting ads versus the other services
cuz the Marine Corp says we're standing
on this wall for the last 250 years and
maybe if you're good enough you can join
us versus hey join up and we're going to
pay for college and the living
conditions are great and we have
excellent golf courses that's not why
Warriors join the military these Marine
Corp ads go hard the future is
threatened by enemies often unrelenting
bra get these people out of here going
to be all right
unexpected and unpredictable
St alert
Marines in the midst of an uncertain and
evolving
world the need for Marines to defeat
these shifting threats is critical I
mean just look at this ad it sums it up
perfectly four crew four mechanics on
the ship job done the Navy did that with
two helicopters and 70 guys that's how
many they had to put on that ship
because they viewed all those bodies as
a free good and for every sorry no it
was two helicopters and 35 guys and then
they had another 70 plus people back in
Stateside waiting to rotate so the the
costs of doing that mission to to keep
two helicopters fielded was basically
the Navy was two helicopters and 100
people that are on their payroll to do
that very easy to do apples to apples
comparison of who is cheaper there's
lots of market-based reforms that can be
done to make the military wake up so
that is why the Marines are succeeding
compared to the other branches if I was
ever the Secretary of Defense I would
hire the head of training from
Chick-fil-A if you've not been through a
Chick-fil-A drive-thru witness what
Chick-fil-A managed to do with with high
school kids in organizing them into a
NASCAR style pit crew of flow that's
impressive and so there's a lot of
lessons that can be learned and imposed
and implemented across the military but
even if you fix this marketing problem
there is still one more major problem
remaining
most American citizens don't qualify for
the military even if they wanted to
serve according to the Pentagon over 34
over 75% of adults aged 17 to 24 are too
obese to qualify or they suffer from a
physical or mental condition that makes
them not qualify that is a huge problem
but then there's also a big portion of
the population that does qualify but
they have a pesky little criminal record
that bans them from serving or they
can't pass a drug test even a tattoo in
the wrong place can completely destroy
your chances of serving in the military
so until we go into a new 80 to 100e
cycle again like what we talked about
earlier where people trust the
government and believe in the nation
again if America gets dragged into
another giant war or even a World War
which seems kind of likely right now the
military really only has one option left
to fix this problem a draft yes that is
right the United States has not had a
military draft in over 50 years but that
doesn't mean it's off the table just
like how Israel has a military draft as
you all know the recent attack on Israel
was absolutely horrifying but there are
a a lot of holes in the official
narrative was it a coincidence that
before the attack happened Israel was
going through extreme civil unrest was
it a coincidence that Israel's leader
Netanyahu was in the midst of standing
trial for corruption and that his
popularity was at an all-time low was it
a coincidence that days before the
attack happened Egypt had warned Israel
of quote something big and yet Israel
ignored their warning was it a
coincidence that one of the most heavily
guarded heavily fortified border walls
in the world could not stop hundreds of
attackers as they blew holes through the
wall and went through it was it a
coincidence that one of the most milit
ized countries in the world that is only
the size of New Jersey where they have a
mandatory draft could not respond to the
attack for 6 long hours was it a
coincidence that once the attack was
over hours later those same attackers
were able to retreat back to Palestine
through those same holes that they blew
in the heavily guarded border wall was
all this really just one big coincidence
well we try to answer that in our new
emergency private documentary that you
can watch right now by clicking the card
on the screen this YouTube membership is
reserved for videos that are just too
controversial to be posted publicly
exactly like this one we still have
another private documentary coming out
within like a week or so on if a certain
German leader were a small mustache
actually off himself so click the card
on the screen to watch
[Music]
now